[MUSIC PLAYING]
JAIME GREEN: Please welcome to
the stage Senator Al Franken.
[APPLAUSE]
AL FRANKEN: Thank you.
Thank you.
JAIME GREEN: Hello.
AL FRANKEN: Thank you, Jaime.
JAIME GREEN: Welcome.
AL FRANKEN: Thank you.
JAIME GREEN: I'd love to start
by talking about what inspired
you to write this book.
A lot of the book is sort of
timeless political memoir.
We get your childhood
and your career
before the Senate and all that.
But as it gets closer
to the current day,
it starts to feel kind of urgent
and specific to our moment.
And so I was curious when you
decided to write this book.
AL FRANKEN: When I decided
to write this book was--
this book is sort
of about answering
the question I get asked
the most, which is,
is being a United States
senator as much fun
as working on
"Saturday Night Live"?
And the answer to that is no.
Why would it be?
But it's the best
job I've ever had,
because you get to
improve people's lives.
And so-- and a lot
of this is also
about the tension of having
been a comedian and a satirist
pretty much all my life, and
then making this transition.
That's the question I
get asked second most,
how did I make that transition?
And I felt free to
start writing this
after I was re-elected,
because my first election was
a 312 vote margin.
And we had a recount.
We had a legal proceeding.
So my wife and I were
going to have a vacation,
six days up in a lodge
in Northern Minnesota.
She was in Washington
with her grandchildren,
and she got sick.
And we were going to go
to Africa immediately
after that vacation on a codel,
a congressional delegation
trip, so she wanted to
just rest up for that.
So I ended up in a
cabin for six days.
And I had threatened to
myself to write about this,
so I started writing about it.
And I was worried
that, you know,
it would just become "The
Shining" or something.
[LAUGHTER]
But it didn't.
It was a lot of
fun, and it actually
helped me think about
being a senator.
And so I try to tell
people how I make
this transition, how I made it.
It had its hairy moments.
That first campaign
was very ugly.
They took every thing that I had
ever said or written in comedy
and put it through this--
you'd be interested
in this machine.
It's called the dehumanizer.
And it had a lot of technology
from Silicon Valley.
And what it does is it
decontextualizes anything
you ever wrote as a joke, and
just takes out all the irony,
hyperbole-- anything
you've done--
and leaves it as something
that you can attack.
And they did that.
For example, I wrote
a piece, I don't
know, around 1999 or
2000, about the internet
and how parents should kind
of monitor what their kids are
doing on the internet.
And I wrote what I think is
a very conservative joke.
I said that, you know,
the internet is great.
My son uses the internet
to do a sixth grade
report on beastiality.
And he downloaded a
lot of great images.
And the kids in the class just
loved them, because you know,
at that age they're
just sponges.
And so that was turned
into an ad which is,
Al Franken jokes
about beastiality.
It kind of comes from infinity
and then goes through your--
the drone.
[DEEP VOICE] Al Franken.
You know?
And so there was a lot of that.
So I won by 312 votes.
And I felt that the
people of Minnesota
deserved to know I was
there for a serious purpose.
So I built my own
dehumanizer, my staff, and--
[LAUGHTER]
I kind of showed people,
Minnesotans especially,
that I was going to be a
workhorse and not a show horse.
And I did that.
I won re-election by a
very comfortable amount.
And it's freed me up to be
a workhorse with a sense
of humor, to be funny again.
JAIME GREEN: Yeah.
Before we go into talking
about your work in the Senate,
I do want to ask one
question about your comedy.
Because you move pretty quickly
through your "SNL" and comedy
writing years in the book.
But one thing that really struck
me was you write about one
of your most famous
characters, Stuart Smalley,
who actually is this ridiculous
mockery of a character
in a lot of ways but
actually came from a really
sincere inspiration.
AL FRANKEN: Yeah.
I don't think of him as
a mockery of a character.
Basically, what happens-- and
I talk about in the campaign,
my wife Franni--
I was being attacked all the
time through those kind of ads.
And she is an alcoholic.
She's a recovering alcoholic.
There was a period where
it was tough, obviously,
on her and on our marriage.
But she talked about how
I stuck it out with her.
And she wanted to talk
about my character.
And she did an ad.
She sat down with
Mandy Grunwald,
who was our media consultant,
and did a beautiful ad.
It's in a chapter called
"Franni Saves the Campaign."
And she just wanted to talk
about how not only did I
stand with her and
support her, but also I
wrote a couple of
movies about this,
one called "A Man Loves a Woman"
with Meg Ryan and Andy Garcia.
She wanted to know
that people did this.
She said something in the ad
that just made me cry and made
Chuck Schumer cry,
which is actually easier
to do than you might think.
[LAUGHTER]
And in this ad, they
showed pictures of us
and our kids and stuff.
She said, how can a mother of
two such beautiful children
be an alcoholic?
And it spoke to the
shame that a lot of women
feel and alcoholics feel.
And it just touched a nerve.
An anchor at the CBS
affiliate in Minneapolis
said, this is the best
political ad of the year
because it's actually an
ad that could help people.
And two days after the ad ran,
we had a debate in a gymnasium.
The place was jammed full,
and people on the floor
and in the bleachers.
When she entered the room,
she got a standing ovation.
And I wouldn't have
won without that ad.
I would have lost
by a lot, I imagine.
So during that time, during
that period of our lives,
I was at "SNL" and
I started going
to Al-Anon, which is
for family members
and friends of alcoholics.
And I learned a
lot about myself.
And one of the things
I learned, which
I'm kind of
embarrassed to say, is
that I learned in
Al-Anon meetings
that you can learn stuff from
people who at first blush
don't seem smart.
And my parents have always
emphasized education,
and you learn from
people who are
educated and smarter than you.
My dad didn't
graduate high school,
so it was very important.
And there was a guy who Stuart
was a little model laughter who
said that the higher
power had put an apartment
in his life one week.
And I just went, ugh.
It was here in New York.
And the next week,
he said something
that just hit me so hard that
was about his experience.
And so I made a character
who was very vulnerable
and kind of at first
blush an idiot,
but to try to explain
what recovery was.
And so that's where
Stuart Smalley was from.
JAIME GREEN: Yeah.
So much of your comedy career
can be defined as satire,
as a satirist.
What's sort of the
impulse behind that?
Because with Stuart, you were
trying to really communicate
something sincere.
AL FRANKEN: Yeah.
I've done really stupid comedy--
you know, Belushi as Liz Taylor
choking on a chicken bone.
Julia Child bleeding to death.
So I've done all kinds.
But I'd always done
political satire.
And it really comes from very,
very early when I was young,
the civil rights
movement was happening.
And my dad, we watched the
news while we ate dinner
on tray tables.
My mom made a great dinner.
It wasn't a TV dinner.
It was a really nice dinner.
But we would watch the news.
This was during the
civil rights struggle.
And when sheriffs would put fire
hoses and billy clubs and dogs
on demonstrators, my dad
would point to the TV and say,
no Jew can be for this.
No Jew can be for this.
And that was a very big lesson
for us, for me and my brother,
about justice, and
why that matters.
And it's one of the reasons--
actually, my dad
was a Republican.
But when Barry Goldwater voted
against the civil rights bill
and was the nominee, he became
a Democrat and stuck with that.
So we lost the South because
of the civil rights bill,
but we gained my dad--
[LAUGHTER]
--and me.
And so I always
cared about politics
and I always wrote
political satire.
And I'm very proud
of the work that I
did in satire on the show.
I write about this.
Jim Downey is a guy
I wrote a lot with.
He was a very
thoughtful conservative.
I like to think I'm a
thoughtful progressive.
We did not feel that
the job of the show
was to have a political bias.
We felt the job of
the show was to do
well-observed political satire.
And Jim and the thing.
It was, we want to reward
people for knowing stuff
but not punish them
for not knowing stuff.
So I think we wrote very well
observed, intelligent satire
that everyone enjoyed.
JAIME GREEN: Yeah.
You mentioned earlier the
dehumanizer of the campaign,
and then bringing that into
your own work in the Senate
and focusing on--
AL FRANKEN: I'll give you an
example of the dehumanizer when
I'm in the Senate.
When the Supreme Court voted
5-4 on marriage equality,
I thought that was
a big day and I
wanted to put out a
press release saying,
I congratulate the Court
for making this decision.
Actually, it was going
to be, Senator Franken
is very happy with
this court's decision
allowing everybody to
marry the person they love,
but Senator Franken felt
that Justice Scalia's dissent
was very gay.
[LAUGHTER]
My team said no.
JAIME GREEN: Really?
AL FRANKEN: Yeah.
No, you can't put that out.
Now, this was after I
had won re-election.
So I thought, oh, come on.
And so we didn't put that out.
But I got it in the book.
It's in the book.
So there's a lot of stuff
in the book that didn't
survive our own dehumanizer.
[LAUGHTER]
JAIME GREEN: But
even as all of that
gets stripped away and
saved for future books,
you have found kind of a
performance venue in your work
in the Senate, which
is committee hearings.
And it might not
have been that way
if this weren't the
age of internet video.
But I sat and watched
your questioning
of Betsy DeVos and other cabinet
nominees and things like that.
So it seems like that committee
work is really high-profile.
How do you end up
on the committees
that you're on in the Senate?
AL FRANKEN: The leader of your
party assigns you to them.
And I had an eight
month process, a recount
and a legal process,
so I got there last.
So I got what
Harry had leftover.
[LAUGHTER]
And so I got judiciary.
I asked for certain
committees and he said no,
and then he told me what I had.
And he said, you'd be
great in judiciary.
And I said, I don't know if
you've noticed this, Harry,
but there are a lot of
lawyers in the Senate.
And I ain't one of them.
And he said, that's
why you'd be great.
And he was bullshitting.
That's what he had.
So I'm on Judiciary.
And I'm really happy I am.
I'm really happy I am.
I've done a lot of judiciary.
And later, I got
what I did ask for,
which is the health committee--
health, education, labor,
and pensions, which is not
that important unless you care
about your health or your
kid's health or your parents'
health or their education
or your education.
[LAUGHTER]
Or if you plan to work
sometime during your life
or maybe retire.
Other than that, it doesn't
have much, uh, jurisdiction.
And then I'm on the
Energy Committee now.
But at that time, I was
put on the Aging Committee.
And Aging Committee is a
nonlegislative committee.
And I actually said
to Harry, aging?
I mean, are people aging?
And he didn't know
that I was kidding.
[LAUGHTER]
Harry's got a very
good sense of humor,
but he didn't know me then.
And so anyway, that's how you
get your committee assignments.
That's the answer
to that question.
[LAUGHTER]
JAIME GREEN: And so with these
sort of hearings and sessions
of questioning being put on
the internet and for everyone
to see them now--
you don't have to sit at home
and watch C-SPAN in order
to catch it--
it can be very entertaining.
AL FRANKEN: And that's a
relief for everybody here
who used to do that.
JAIME GREEN: I know.
It was really interfering
with their work, [INAUDIBLE].
But they can be
very entertaining,
and certainly galvanizing.
But I'm curious,
within the Senate,
how those hearings function.
Do they actually affect votes?
What do you see the role of
those performances to be?
AL FRANKEN: Well, I don't
consider it a performance.
I consider it a hearing.
And I consider a hearing
as a serious thing,
where you're representing--
I'm representing the people of
Minnesota in those hearings,
and I want to ask questions
I want the answers to.
Sometimes the effect
of the hearing--
we did not stop
people from-- like,
we did not stop Betsy DeVos
from getting confirmed.
The vice president, for
the first time in history,
had to come down and cast
the tie-breaking vote
to get her confirmed.
But I felt that she did not
know education policy, which
for the Secretary of Education
is an issue, I think.
And so I demonstrated
that in my questioning.
Sometimes the
questioning is something
that exists for the record.
In the judiciary hearings, I
asked Jeff Sessions a question
that he responded to by
saying that he had not
met with any Russians
during the campaign.
That turned out not to be true.
And he's under oath, and
that's a serious thing.
But we didn't find that out till
well after he'd been confirmed.
And there's some
news breaking today,
possibly, about that,
about Senator Leahy and I,
after we were not satisfied
with his answers about why
he had not disclosed his
meetings with the Russians--
which seems to be
something that there's
a pattern of this, shall we say,
in the Trump administration.
They aren't acting like people
who have nothing to hide.
And because of his not
answering my question,
or answering my question
in the way he did--
not truthfully-- he ended
up recusing himself.
And because he recused
himself, Rod Rosenstein,
the Deputy Attorney
General, assigned
the special
prosecutor, ultimately.
And so that's why we have
a special prosecutor.
So sometimes you do things
to get things on the record.
JAIME GREEN: That makes sense.
Yeah.
So in the book, you
also write about being
friends with many of your
Republican colleagues
in the Senate.
And you write about how
you're friends with them
even though you vigorously
disagree with them.
AL FRANKEN: Sure.
JAIME GREEN: And I
would love to hear
you talk about that a little,
because it seems like--
it's not just, oh, I think
we should tax at 18%.
I think we should tax at 14%.
These are huge, almost
moral disagreements.
And I think that it can be
very relevant to those of us
not working in the Senate
too because they're
your colleagues, but some
of us have friends or family
or colleagues with whom we
have these similar, very, very
deep disagreements.
So how do you maintain
those relationships?
AL FRANKEN: Well,
we're a workplace.
And you want to be
a good coworker.
The way to get things done
in the Senate is to have--
you're living in a town
that has 100 people in it,
and your word has to be good.
And that's more than anything.
And I bonded with a
number of Republicans
right away just with humor.
Jim DeMint, a very
right-wing senator
at the time from
South Carolina-- now
he's head of the
Heritage Foundation--
came up to me on the
floor the first day
I was there and said, how
are things on the far left?
I said, they're great.
How are things on
the nutcase right?
[LAUGHTER]
And he laughed, and we
continued having a relationship
while he was in
the Senate, based
on just giving each other crap.
But it was a good relationship.
Lindsey Graham is really funny.
When he was like 16th out of
17 in the presidential race,
I went up to him
and said, you know,
Lindsey, if I were voting
in the Republican primaries,
I'd vote for you.
And he said, that's my problem.
[LAUGHTER]
Now, I have one
colleague, Tom Coburn,
who didn't seem to have
any sense of humor.
So my first four or
five exchanges with him
were not good.
And I went up to him.
I said, Tom, can I
take you to lunch?
He said, tell you what.
Take me to breakfast.
And Tom was kind
of called Dr. No,
because he was a medical doctor
before he went into the Senate,
and he also was very,
very big on spending.
He wanted to balance the budget.
And he said no to
a lot of things,
and used his privileges
to stop a lot of stuff.
So we go to breakfast
the next day.
At the beginning of
breakfast I said, look--
we're in the Senate
dining room--
I said, over the
next 45 minutes,
we can talk about anything.
We can talk about politics,
talk about our families,
talk about our
careers before here.
But let's have fun, OK?
He goes, OK, let's have fun.
We'll have fun.
So I said, OK, now,
let's talk about careers.
You were a doctor
before you came here.
Let me ask you something.
To be a doctor in
Oklahoma, do you have
to have any formal education?
[LAUGHTER]
And he said,
[SHOUTING] yes, you've
got to go to medical school.
[LAUGHTER]
And I said, OK, that was a joke.
You see, that's what
I did for my career.
And then we had a delightful
breakfast in which
I taught him what jokes were--
[LAUGHTER]
--and what proper response was.
And he wrote me a note
afterwards and said
he had a delightful breakfast.
And we got along really well.
And so I write
about Ted Cruz, who
seems to be the
exception to the rule.
JAIME GREEN: Yeah.
We're going to open it up
to questions in a minute,
so if you have a
question, you can line up
at one of the microphones.
But I want to ask
one more question.
So you point out in the book
that once President Obama was
elected, the Republican
plan in Congress
just became obstruction.
Stop him from getting
anything done.
And that hasn't changed.
They still are trying
to stop anything--
AL FRANKEN: No, I
mean, it has changed.
We have a different
from President.
Mitch McConnell said something
that kind of shocked me.
He said, our number one goal is
to see to it that Barack Obama
is a one-term president.
And I wasn't shocked
that he thought
that but I was shocked that
he said it out loud, because I
think our number one goal should
be to improve people's lives,
to provide a world-class
education to our kids,
to make sure that our
economy is working,
to make sure that veterans
get the care they need.
There's a lot of
things that must
come before partisan politics.
So I was shocked about that.
But he used the
rules of the Senate
to try to stop Barack Obama
from having any achievements.
And I have a chapter called
"The Great Curdling."
And things curdled during
that period and got very bad.
When I first got
there, it was bad.
And I asked a colleague who had
been there for about 30 years,
I said, was it always this bad?
No, no, no, no.
I said, has it ever
been worse than this?
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Remember when that
guy got caned?
And I said, Charles Sumner
who got caned like right
before the Civil War?
And he goes, yeah,
that was worse.
[LAUGHTER]
JAIME GREEN: OK.
That's reassuring.
AL FRANKEN: Yeah.
[LAUGHTER]
So you write in the book,
by the time you read this,
Republicans may
well have succeeded
in repealing some or all
of the Affordable Care Act.
But I'm willing to bet
they won't have succeeded
in replacing it, because
the truth is they've never
been interested in addressing
the central challenge, which
I think applies sort of
broadly to that curdling.
So if they're not trying to
pass legislation that will
improve or replace Obamacare--
AL FRANKEN: This is the
thing about the book.
We did education together
in the health committee.
And Lamar Alexander was
very good in that process.
And it took us a while, but
we ultimately passed a bill
that we all were happy with.
And we can do it.
So it depends on the issue.
But on health
care, I don't think
the Republicans thought Donald
Trump would become president.
They assumed Hillary would
be and they could still
continue to use Obamacare
just as a political bludgeon.
And I don't think
that they have given--
Donald Trump said
that nobody knew
that health care was
complicated until he figured out
that it was complicated.
It's very complex, our
health care system.
And I don't think that many
of my Republican colleagues--
and I know this for sure,
because I've talked to many
of them--
have really thought through what
to replace the Affordable Care
Act with.
That's what I was writing about.
And of course, we're
seeing a process
that I think is the wrong
process in the Senate right
now, where 13 Republicans
are behind closed doors.
They're not currently.
They're in recess.
But they're trying to
come up with something.
We should be doing this.
There should be an open process.
We should be doing it like
we did the Affordable Care
Act, through committees.
JAIME GREEN: All right.
We're going to open it
up to questions now.
AUDIENCE: Hi, Senator.
Thank you for coming.
AL FRANKEN: Sure, thank you.
AUDIENCE: I imagine you probably
get this question all the time,
but for people who
are not politics
are going in the US right
now, what can we do about it?
AL FRANKEN: If you're
not happy, get involved.
Get engaged.
Throwing your hands up and
saying things are terrible
is not a way to make
our system work better.
It just leaves it to the people
who are cynical and don't care.
So I am very much heartened by
the reaction that we've had.
The Women's March on Washington
was an amazing event.
And people going to town
hall meetings, I think,
helped defeat the
House health care
bills that were the predecessor
to this horrible bill.
But get involved in
an advocacy group.
If you care about
mental health, then
advocate for funding
for mental health
or getting more mental
health providers.
If you care about
climate change,
an existential threat to us
all, get involved in that.
And you'll be
surprised, you become
a foot soldier in
an organization,
how quickly you
become an officer
and how quickly you're
lobbying Congress.
And it makes a difference.
It really does.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AL FRANKEN: Thank you.
JAIME GREEN: You said
earlier that your sort
of overarching goal is to
serve the people of Minnesota
when you're in the Senate.
How much do phone calls or
emails from your constituents
influence your work?
AL FRANKEN: They do.
And the ones that make
the biggest difference
are the ones that clearly aren't
liked from some AstroTurf group
where you get the
same written email.
If you're writing a actual--
but they make a difference.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I'm Joy.
I actually graduated last
year from Carleton College.
AL FRANKEN: Oh, great school.
AUDIENCE: And
speaking of getting
involved, I've actually
been to your office
multiple times with Sam and
Sylvia and other [INAUDIBLE]
delegations.
I was really excited to
hear that you were coming.
I am sort of
curious, because when
I speak to a lot
of people my age,
they're starting to lose faith.
They're going out
to these marches
and going to town halls,
and it seems to them
like the Democratic
Party, in a lot of ways,
is playing defense.
And that, to a certain
extent, makes sense
for where we are right now.
I'm curious if you could speak
to any coordinated efforts
on behalf of the party to
really go back on the offense
and take back some power,
rather than waiting
until the elections in 2018.
AL FRANKEN: Well,
we have a system
and elections have consequences,
so it's hard for us
to be on offense.
We're on offense
in our messaging.
We're on offense in many ways.
But we are in the
minority in both houses,
and the White House is
controlled by Donald Trump's
the president.
So we--
[LAUGHTER]
I try to play offense.
I try to play offense
in the hearings.
AUDIENCE: Are there
cooridnated efforts, thougth?
Because I see you
playing offense,
and I see Senator Warren and
Keith Ellison playing offense.
But are there coordinated
efforts to do so?
AL FRANKEN: Yeah.
Democrats sometimes have
problems with messaging.
The way I like to put it--
and I put it in the book--
is that our bumper
stickers always and with,
continued on next
bumper sticker.
[LAUGHTER]
I mean, it's not like we're
not trying, believe me.
We're trying to be on
offense at all times.
AUDIENCE: If that's the problem,
what are you doing to fix it?
AL FRANKEN: What am I
going to do to fix it?
I can only-- I myself am
doing my job the best I can,
and I'm being as aggressive as
I can when it's appropriate.
And in this book, I write
about victories that matter,
that matter in people's lives.
My first bill, I passed two
weeks after I got to Congress--
my co-sponsor, Johnny Isakson,
a Republican from Georgia--
was to get service
dogs to veterans
from Iraq and
Afghanistan who have PTSD
and traumatic brain injury
and other invisible wounds,
because these dogs
help them tremendously.
And that is, to me--
I've gotten increased funding
for mental health in schools.
That is an enormous victory for
me that I really care about.
I'm on the offensive,
believe me.
And we are on the offensive
on this health care
bill, this terrible,
awful health care
bill that has an $880 billion
cut in Medicaid-- which,
the president said he
would never cut Medicaid.
We're pointing that out.
And people are freaked out
about it in rural Minnesota.
I can tell you that.
And all over Minnesota.
But I'm Co-Chair of the
Rural Health Caucus,
so I go all around
rural Minnesota.
I'm on the offense.
I'm doing the best I can.
Chuck Schumer is
doing the best we can.
Tom Perez is doing
the best he can.
We will fall short and
disappoint you all the time.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AL FRANKEN: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Thank you, senator.
If you look at different
types of charts--
if you look at charts
of income inequality,
if you look at
charts that examine
congressional legislation
compared to public opinion,
and most importantly,
if you look
at statistical data of outcomes
of congressional campaigns
and congressional elections
versus the amount of money
spent on the campaigns,
our democracy
resembles more of an oligarchy.
If you can say, as
you can in the States,
that you can pretty much
predict with high accuracy
the outcome of an election
based on the money spent on it,
it's hard to claim that
this is a democracy,
because the people's
opinion clearly matters
much less than the money spent.
Given that, it seems like
our democratic process
is running with its hands
tied behind its back.
How can we achieve
anything significant
before we address this very
serious problem of campaign
financing?
And why do we not hear more
about this from Congress?
AL FRANKEN: You know,
one of the worst
parts of having Donald Trump
as president instead of Hillary
Clinton is who they--
we have Neil Gorsuch now
as the ninth justice.
I was hoping that
Hillary would win--
I fought very hard for her--
so that we would
get a justice who
would overturn
Citizens United, which
is one of the most pernicious
decisions we've seen.
It's interesting that Justice
Kennedy wrote the majority
opinion in that.
He said, this doesn't
present even the appearance
of corruption.
[LAUGHTER]
And he said that
because of the internet,
everyone will be able to
see who gave what to whom.
He envisioned, and their
decision envisioned,
disclosure.
And we tried to get
disclosure done.
And every Republican
voted against it.
At that point, we had 15--
this is after Scott Brown had
won in Massachusetts.
They needed 41 and they had 41.
You're absolutely
right about this.
I mean, you can say that
Hillary spent more than Trump.
And that was the big one.
He got a lot of free
media, because people
were entertained by him.
But you're right.
There's a book that
Sheldon Whitehouse
has written called
"Captured," which
talks about how big corporations
and big special interests
have captured a
number of things--
including, through campaign
finance stuff, our elections--
the ability for people
to get in the court.
Our regulatory agencies
sometimes get captured.
The courts are captured.
It's a problem.
One thing I can say is that
most Americans agree with you.
The vast majority of
Americans agree with you.
But if you ask them, what's the
most important issue to you?
It comes out eighth
or ninth or tenth.
It is an existential threat.
AUDIENCE: It should be first.
So who's championing
this in the Senate?
AL FRANKEN: Well, we are
fighting for reform and losing.
But it's people like
Sheldon Whitehouse.
It's people like--
I've been in this fight.
It's been Elizabeth
Warren, Bernie.
I mean, Dick Durbin has always
led for public financing
of elections.
And I agree with that.
I've been a co-sponsor of
his legislation to do that.
We just don't have--
the Republican Party
will not do this.
So right now, we are
not winning that one.
JAIME GREEN: OK, thanks.
Over here?
AUDIENCE: Hi, senator.
Thanks for coming.
You mentioned that you work with
a lot of lawyers in Congress.
And I'm wondering if you think
that lawyers and prosecutors
in particular are more
qualified to serve in Congress,
or if perhaps lawyers are
sort of more accommodating
of doublespeak and dishonesty
that I think frustrates
us in politics.
[LAUGHTER]
AL FRANKEN: Well, a lot of
my colleagues are lawyers.
And there's colleagues
that I admire tremendously
who are lawyers, and
there are colleagues
that I don't admire
tremendously who are lawyers.
I think probably when Harry said
I'd be good on the committee
because I'm not a
lawyer, I actually
think that I play
a good role there.
I think my training
as a satirist--
I can spot inconsistencies.
Satirists are trained in
a certain kind of way.
And because of the books
I wrote, "Lies and Lying
Liars Who Tell Them,"
[INAUDIBLE], or "Rush Limbaugh
is a Big Fat Idiot and
Other Observations,"
all very high-minded books
of satire, trained me.
And that's why I think I've had
a high profile in my hearings,
because I think I
know how to frame
things because of
my training and know
how to make something land.
So we are making the laws, so
being a lawyer has its upside.
But I think you're
right, I'd like
to see people who
aren't lawyers.
By the way, I want to just
say one thing very quickly.
And I maybe shouldn't
be so quick about this.
But I write it in the
book, because there's
a lot of despair
hanging on the room.
There's hope here.
In 2004, we lost the White House
in a very, very close election.
And George W. Bush,
I think by then,
it was apparent that we had
really been lied into the war,
that they had made the
decision to go to war
and then kind of cooked
the books and the evidence
to get us there.
And that was a very
difficult defeat.
But we came back.
And it was because of things
like Air America, which
I was a radio host for.
It was things like
Media Matters, which
answered the
right-wing messaging
machine in a very
effective way, the Center
for American Progress, a
progressive think tank.
And in '06, we took
the Congress back.
And in '08, we had Barack
Obama win the White House.
And we had for a moment, for
a couple of months, 60 votes.
So don't despair.
Get active is what I'm saying.
AUDIENCE: Hi, senator.
Thanks for coming.
So we hear a lot about
how the best way to resist
the Trump administration,
the GOP's current agenda,
is to call our congresspeople
and call our senators.
So I live in New York City.
And New York City
has very liberal
congresspeople and
liberal senators,
so I like calling
them is maybe not
as effective as calling swing
representatives or swing
senators.
So do you have any suggestions
for effective ways for people
like me who live in
liberal districts
to put pressure on
members of Congress
or to help Democrats win control
of the House back in 2018?
AL FRANKEN: Well, yes.
We have districts
in America that
are very blue, like in
New York, or very red.
If you look at a
map of the country,
you know where those are.
So I think you guys could
Google those pretty well, right?
So some of you, I
think, are paid OK.
And you can actually
give money to candidates
who are running in
swing districts,
for example, or to organizations
that believe in the things
you believe in.
When I talked
about advocacy, you
can join advocacy
groups that speak
to everybody if it's about
an issue that you care about.
If you care about housing, if
you care about clean water,
you can join
advocacy groups that
are national advocacy groups.
And then you're talking about
an issue that lobbies everybody
in Congress or tries
to speak to everybody--
and not only that, but
people in state houses
and in local government.
And all of that is
very, very important.
There is an infinite
amount to do,
and you can find something to do
if you work hard enough at it.
But other than just call Chuck
Schumer, probably you're right.
Chuck probably believes, or
Kirsten Gillibrand, probably--
what I'm getting
is they probably
already agree with you, yeah.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AL FRANKEN: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hello, senator.
Thank you for coming here today.
I'm actually from
Minnesota myself,
and it's really heartwarming
to see you looking out
for the interests
of Minnesotans,
bringing Minnesota
nice to the Senate.
But I think there's
another group of people
who could really use your help,
who could use some of the hope
that you were talking about.
And that's the people
in New York City.
I'm wondering what we
can do here in New York
to bring the spirit of
Minnesota to our everyday lives.
[LAUGHTER]
AL FRANKEN: Where are you from?
AUDIENCE: Minneapolis,
northeast.
AL FRANKEN: I've heard of it.
[LAUGHTER]
It starts from each of you.
I want each of you
to be nice today.
I want it to emanate
from this Google campus.
Every person can be nice.
[LAUGHTER]
But in Minnesota, you're
also passive aggressive.
That's also--
[LAUGHTER]
And talk like this, kind
of [MINNESOTA ACCENT], hey,
how you doin'?
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AL FRANKEN: You're welcome.
[MINNESOTA ACCENT] So,
who do we got here?
AUDIENCE: Oh, hi.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So Sergey Brin said
once in one of these talks
in this room--
so he had met Obama after
Obama's re-election,
and he suggested to Obama that
the president disassociate from
the Democratic Party, just
for the sake of breaking down
the division between
the two parties--
which is, like, probably,
obviously, ridiculous.
But Sergey wasn't joking,
and obviously he's smart.
So I'm just wondering,
he's getting
at a real issue of how the
party barriers get in the way.
So I'm wondering how
ridiculous you think that is.
AL FRANKEN: Very.
[LAUGHTER]
Very ridiculous.
In the book, I think--
would you agree with
this-- that I kind of
try to talk about how it
really is, how it really works.
And not in a cynical way.
JAIME GREEN: No.
[LAUGHTER]
AL FRANKEN: This is
how we're going to do
the whole thing from now on.
But that's just not
going to happen.
That wasn't going to happen.
And the Republicans
had done everything
they could to defeat him.
And no, he was not
going to divorce himself
from the Democratic Party.
AUDIENCE: But what if
it's not a president?
What if it's somebody
else in that situation?
AL FRANKEN: Well,
people do that.
I mean, Bernie Sanders is not a
member of the Democratic Party.
So people are free to do that.
And people do that.
But I'm a Democrat.
I'm a Democrat, because--
and I start the book
about why I'm a Democrat.
And I'm a Democrat.
I grew up in St.
Louis Park, Minnesota.
My dad didn't
graduate high school.
He was a printing salesman.
I grew up in a two-bedroom,
one-bath house.
But I felt like the
luckiest kid in the world,
because I was growing
up middle class,
at the height of the middle
class, in the '50s in America
in Minnesota in St.
Louis Park, and I
felt like I could do
anything I wanted.
And I don't feel like kids
feel that way today, maybe.
But when I went to
college, I met my wife.
And she didn't grow up that way.
Her father died when
she was 18 months old.
She had a younger sister.
Her mom was widowed at
age 29 with five kids.
And they made it because
of Social Security survivor
benefits.
Sometimes they didn't
have enough to eat.
A lot of times.
Sometimes the heat
was turned off.
And this is in Portland, Maine.
Sometimes the phone
was turned off.
But they made it.
And all the girls
went to college
on combinations of Pell
grants, which at that time
paid for about 80% of a
public college education,
and scholarships.
And my mother-in-law ended
up going to college when
the youngest--
there was one younger my wife.
When the youngest went to high
school, she got a GI loan.
Her husband fought
in World War II.
And that allowed her
to go to college.
She ended up being a teacher.
She taught Title
I kids, poor kids,
so all her loans were forgiven.
They tell you in this
country to pull yourself up
by the bootstraps.
I think we all believe that.
But first, you have
to have the boots.
And the federal government
gave Franni's family the boots.
And that's what we believe. in.
We believe in creating
opportunity for everybody.
And I think that
this president--
witness his budget, witness
his health care legislation--
doesn't believe that.
And that's why I'm a Democrat.
Yes?
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: First
of all, thank you,
senator, for leading by
example and showing us
that you can go from
commenting on the process
to actually do something
and living that.
So thank you.
AL FRANKEN: Thank
you for saying that.
AUDIENCE: In terms of advocacy
and what we care about,
you could say a few
people in this room care
a little bit about the
quality of information
and how it's delivered.
AL FRANKEN: Thank god.
If you guys didn't, who would?
AUDIENCE: There's a lot
of noise between all
of the information out there and
how it gets to everyday people.
And I'm very interested
to find out from you
how you cut through all that.
And which medium have you found
to be the most clearcut channel
to get directly from what
you want to communicate
to your constituents?
Because I've seen how you've
done it through humor and books
over the years.
And on a personal note, what you
did on Air America radio with
Janeane Garofalo-- and Rachel
Maddow was on right before
you--
that helped me
connect as a citizen.
I was right out of college, just
started in the tech industry.
And in terms of--
I home-schooled myself and
went to community college
and went to college, and
now I work at Google.
20 years later-- it's my
20-year reunion this year--
I now can afford to pay off my
student loans, 20 years later.
I'm doing it this year in
honor of my 20-year reunion.
The things that you connected
to me through radio,
through just an
audio channel alone,
felt like an audience
of one to me,
like I got the most
as a citizen from you,
and you weren't
even a senator yet.
So now, as a senator, you speak
directly to your constituents,
I imagine.
You also speak through
the dehumanizer.
What's the most
effective channel,
and how do you connect with
your constituents the most
and how do you cut
through all that?
AL FRANKEN: Ed, my
communications chief, is here.
We try to use any tool we can.
We try to use social media.
I try to do it when
I have a platform.
And if I have a platform
in a hearing, I use it.
Floor speeches.
Speeches-- hopefully this
is going to reach people.
This is why net
neutrality, to me,
is a huge First
Amendment issue, and why
I believe that
people have to fight
what the FCC is
trying to reverse,
the open internet rule.
And I think this is
very, very dangerous.
We've always had net
neutrality on the internet.
And it's from the
very beginning,
when it was the arpanet--
I'm sorry, when
DARPA had started it,
we need to preserve that
so that all information is
treated equally.
I think that's
absolutely essential.
And we can't have huge
corporate interests,
and especially internet
service providers,
deciding what information
gets to flow free
and what you have to
pay for, et cetera.
So again, it's also
an existential issue.
We have many
existential issues--
campaign finance
reform, net neutrality,
climate change for God's sakes.
We haven't discussed that.
We're at Google, so we
should be discussing this.
So that's one thing I've
been leading the charge on,
is net neutrality.
I try to get my message
out any way I can.
And if you have anybody here
that can help us, let us know.
OK?
Thank you.
And thanks for the
really kind words.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
JAIME GREEN:
Unfortunately, I think
that's all we have
time for today.
But thank you so much, senator,
for coming in to talk with us.
[APPLAUSE]